in today's and on your side what is the
future of e-commerce well it's looking
very very strong kirsten joyce reports
the u.s department of commerce is
actually projecting that sales are going
to go up every single year for the
foreseeable future so if we think the
shopping
that brick and mortar stores are having
a tough time now they haven't seen
anything yet joe stefani is the
president of desert cactus a licensed
product company for the nba nhl
department of defense and more than 700
universities he's seen double-digit
growth every quarter since the pandemic
began he's also anticipating what
e-commerce will look like in the future
as customer demands change they want to
see more images and that's something if
you go back a couple years ago you know
the average consumer would be okay with
having one or two images of a product
now the customer wants to see six seven
eight images they want to see a 360
degree view of the product more videos
of a product and augmented reality what
something looks like inside your own
home you can also add a quicker delivery
time as well people wanted to see it
next day or same day so you're going to
start seeing a lot more fulfillment
centers like specifically with amazon
being built within your community itself
and that way then you have a better
chance of getting the product let's say
the same day kiersten joyce 8 news now